the videos that are lovely you sat in
frontal in real life sir
they copy that long all right in
textbook they want you to calculate okay
so I'm going to put down the equations
and some boundaries for you okay so
they're what you think I know what
happens when you take the area between
this this and these boundaries this is
odd so I don't think I've signed it but
you may then which to take that area and
then rotate it around the ant census so
the volume around the x-axis okay so
Mikey Detroit okay yeah by the way
number one you don't have to draw it but
if you do me a volume you really should
number two we don't usually expect your
drawings particularly if you don't have
to do it they're not stipulated we don't
usually expect them to be super accurate
okay
but I reckon how do you look at these
functions and the values that you've
been given which are very nice values
okay I reckon you can almost draw it to
scale you don't have to of course but it
will just make your diagram a little
easier to read honestly okay to give it
a go draw it up work out the volume and
then we're going to talk about it and
some special things about it you say
okay a lot of you have been getting the
on top and you've been getting it right
which is which is great okay but you
guys are so I'd like to see if you
really know why you're right
because they just I when you do get such
a straight ball question it is very
straightforward the numbers are really
nice the functions are very simple okay
when it's hard are you going to need to
be more confident okay now here's the
first major criticism I have of all of
you okay
it's probably not a deal breaker but
it's the reason why most of you when you
say I don't really know what the answer
is you can't justify whether it's one or
the other
most of you have drawn your functions I
can that looks all right
and then you value said okay look I want
this thing defines an area so most of
you have kind of
that something like this okay so there's
your area and that's where you stop and
you start to compute a volume okay now
to your credit most of you have actually
computed the bite on you you so much
food whether it is here's what I would
encourage you to do okay drool to both
drool the boy I'm gonna argue from my
drawing in a second if I don't have it
back on so here's the way I recommend
you do this and you all really need to
learn how to draw a bunny
okay very important things hello look at
all the important points the points that
define your area the vertices if you
like that's going to be rotated okay so
for me I see three vertices can you see
them as well you got this point of
intersection yeah and then you've got
these two points that sort of come from
this boundary okay so one two three now
what you do is if you need to get a
ruler up because I'm rotating around the
x-axis I'm going to take those three
vertices and flip them across the x-axis
because that's where they want to end up
so for instance if you got good eyesight
you might just be able to see this
matches here okay now when I rotate
around right that point down there
they're affected by ought to be the on
the opposite side of the circle or the
diameter if you lack of my volume okay
my soul that of revolution so he's our
drawer Hey
you're reflected across that you scale
it with decent what happens here I'm
gonna do this big one like sir now
rather do the other side just like here
I'm gonna do it Donna can't even tell me
why that part of the volume is there and
that part is shaped but you can't
actually see it because it's a solid I'd
see I have the restrictor five years
from now I have that one last vertice
pair of vertices into the vertex I can't
see them at all so I had them drawn in
like that not to complete at the body
this shape or to mirrored here yeah so
I'm gonna get this kind of shape it's
just gently curved there you go and just
to help me out a little bit I'm gonna
put some shading on here to make them
volume more obvious okay so for instance
you can put it things like this
okay so you can see that what you're
looking at inside there
that's illegal cylindrical shape right
what's gonna happen is it bends in
toward I'm just toward this hole right
so it's not this hole just going
straight down it actually sort of curves
inward and it's smaller here than it is
over there if you want to put a few more
lines in sort of like this way but after
that you start to put more lines in it
becomes warm school rather less so
there's my volume okay now how do I work
out how do I evaluate what the holding
is just think about it without this read
or quit polar bear they say forget the
idea that it's hollow at first and if I
want to work out that volume
what intra-group would I form let's just
start with the formula first without any
specific functions in it
what I start with very first thing hey
why is there a pie there because it's
circular
as you'll see in a second if you count
remember this is just constant PI R
squared right
what I have here I have my upper and
lower bounds then I've got now is it x
squared dy or is it Y squared DX now how
can you tell
the way I always think about it is which
way you're rotating that's your with
respect to X you're rotating with
respect to X if that makes sense
so there's your X and the other one must
be yeah so there's your PI Oscar okay
let's evaluate so you apply one to four
of now remember I just said imagine if
it was solid without that we had hole in
the middle so what would you define as
quiet it's the outside isn't it that's
what's going to give you the being solid
okay so it's square of x squared so
you're just going to get X yes okay we
can evaluate that yeah all right now if
I want to get rid of this volume in the
middle all I need to do is calculate
that body and subtract
yes so in fact I should really have over
here right the subtraction of another
whole volume so it should look like this
it'll be the other function I guess I'll
call it Y DX so in this case one to four
what's Y Square to me just whatever X
which by the way is the sole reason why
a piece of this exercise with respect to
X so if I so good okay right now because
we've got that same constant coefficient
at the front of both you had the same
operand operand cofounder ease for both
you can combine these two integrals yeah
so you can say PI 1 2 4 X minus 1 over X
or with respect to X and then off we go
ok let's keep the computer
what's the primitive topic squid - oh
yes between one and four what's going to
happen let's see half of 4 squared is 8
minus 4
yeah - low about half of 1 squared is
1/2 by this log of 1 which is 0 so you
work to get I suppose you can call that
2 log 2 you don't gain all that much it
doesn't factor eyes out I'm just going
to leave it it's a volume so I suppose I
want to say